in western society today and documents
like the United Nations you memorize
human rights documents yeah is that
gonna be the better basis or is kind of
Islamic Scripture going to be the better
basis I think it's I think it's very
easy to show that's it that's you know
that you know accessible create tolerant
society that doesn't allow can I come
back a few points because I think what
you've done there you've done it done a
really good job in trying your best okay
you also mentioned sorry you also
mentions have like the the narrative of
weather was kind of um the you know the
western countries who coerced and
pressured and advised the Muslim
countries to actually abolish slavery
and he says oh no that's rubbish and I
think kind of like you know history wool
I don't say that was wrong no I thought
I said that the time you're talking
about was ironically a time where
Western countries had been colonizing
the thing they're like okay the Western
countries in like 1850 you know they did
all these bad things so who are they to
some countries which Muslim countries
Western if you're going to make the case
that it is you know an Islamic um you
know doctrine to end slavery because of
this person have the Quran that says
that kind of some of the zakat money
should go towards freeing slaves then
you need to try and account for why it
is that Muslim countries ended up being
so much slower okay no problem than
Western for you I have allowed you to
speak so I think okay I should I have to
say you've tried your best and based on
yeah you've tried your best
you have you have made some couple
points although some of the you've made
some equivocations and I have to point
them out okay
first equivocation that you made you use
the word good and bad now good and
violent liberal basis depends on what's
legitimate and illegitimate what was
acceptable was not acceptable
what's mandated and what's not mandated
so if I say it's acceptable its mandated
and legitimate on political liberalism
that you can have slaves for instance
and I can make that I can make the
argument using the social contract if I
say it's legitimate it's acceptable and
so on on liberalism on political
liberalism to have colonies right just
like John Stuart Mill would agree with
me just like John Locke would agree with
me just like Immanuel Kant would agree
with me just like Montesquieu would
agree with me just like the American
Founding Fathers will agree with me the
righties of the Federalist Papers would
agree with me and so on and so forth
then it's a different case to make
because when you say good and bad now
good and bad is defined by liberalism if
you're a liberal now you have different
kinds of liberalism so you have
political liberalism
now what's desirable on political
liberalism might be differentiated by
the way by what is desirable on social
liberalism okay and I'll give you an
example of that like utilitarian based
liberalism the type of which that John
Stuart Mill defended and wrote a book
called on utilitarianism in chapter 4 he
talked about how to distill preview' top
is called proving utilitarianism and
then he talked about that which is
desirable which makes you happy is that
which is good that's what he said so if
you talk about social liberalism having
a slave on social liberalism could only
be objected to on the basis of the harm
principle now if there's a structure a
politically politically legitimized
structure on liberalism of colonialism
for instance which entails a kind of
exploitation or slavery in essence
that could be acceptable both on
political liberalism and on social
liberalism so I think the idea here
because there's two things worth doing
we have to look at the principles and
then we have to look at the history okay
now the history might not always be in
line with the principles and vice versa
it could be the case that in abstraction
in philosophical abstraction that the
principles allow these things happen but
that in historical reality those things
did not happen and vice versa
now what I'm saying to you I'm putting
to you is that there is nothing for
example in liberalism which abolishes or
does anything to do with racism there
were many liberals racists and there's
nothing within liberalism social
liberalism political liberalism of any
kind of economic liberalism
sorry okay a political liberalism which
says for example racism is wrong so if
someone wants to predicate an exploit
eight exploitation or economic
relationship on a racial system on
liberalism then that could be justified
philosophically in abstraction there's
nothing and that's why you find up into
Wilson Church or you have racist people
in this country and other countries in
the West why because there's nothing
within their worldview which stops
racism they were forced to be
multicultural when they begged you know
the second world countries that they
once colonized subjects from those
countries to come back into the country
so that they can build their
infrastructure and they knew that they
had to to get along with them in order
to make societies work that's why racism
was was seen as bad it's not really with
liberalism it's not only with human
rights because human rights is is an
extension of liberalism and in fact I
don't you can occur I even recall in the
Human Rights document that which
explicitly condemns you know this kind
of attitude inherent attitude within a
human being so the point I'm making to
you is this
if I said slavery is a good thing as a
liberal you couldn't even refute that
statement and if I believe that to be
the case you can't say that's good
enough bad because good and bad is
something which is determined by the
mechanisms that different liberal
philosophers put down and you can't
prove philosophically that that is bad
according to liberalism is back
colonization is bad slavery exploitation
relation in fact you could argue that
the kind of supply-side economics that
you that you once referred to that was
espoused by people like Adam Smith and
that was objected to by people like John
Keane Maynard Keynes who of course had
this different model yeah and so on
that kind of liberalism actually
facilitates the exploitation
relationships which which you can argue
compound compound what I'm not gonna use
these terms but this this relationship
surplus values
mucks cooled it surplus value right so
the idea of the worker in the working
and all that kind of stuff
exploitation happens in capitalism so
you can even make you an economic case
against liberalism and say look this
what's happening now is the IMF bank
which is legitimate from economic
liberal perspective where they're given
the African subcontinent two countries
these big loans that they can't pay back
and that now that's effectively put in
half the population into slavery and now
they have to do this and that and the
other rule to pay them back it might not
be direct slavery but it's an
economically sanctioned slavery of
exploitation capitalistic exploitation
which is legitimate on put on economic
liberalism sanctioned by political
liberalism and not contradicted by
social liberalism therefore we have to
be honest what we're saying is that I
think you have this trajectory of okay
the white Savior ISM complex that the
white man came with his Western ideas to
help us brown people understand what
true morality was and what isn't is
actually a false notion on liberalism
because there's nothing inherent nothing
which in here is within that philosophy
which objects to racism which objects
use exploitation which expect objects--
to colonialism and so on so I think that
the argument is a flawed one is a good
attempt to refute me about it wasn't it
wasn't a philosophically a satiating one
yeah it was a good try it was a nice
right but I will say to you while
synthesis is that in Islam I'll repeat
this we don't we're not apologist to the
liberal world because I said to you I'm
quoting scholars from the medieval world
before
well ghazali work oh it died
one-one-one-one yes he died 1111 he
wrote a book called al-mustafa talking
about the O soul and this and that and
and the objects of Sharia he himself
said in parts of his works that slavery
the objective of it is to do away with
it
yes we said this this is not a response
to the liberal that's forcing us to say
this no this is we said this before John
Locke even lived you know this was five
or six hundred years before John Locke
so the point is the systems were in
place we have a justifiable moral reason
to say that freeing slaves is a good
thing and that is what the Quran says
well Matt as the rock camel Aqaba
you acaba what is the good way
freeing slaves
that's the Quran they don't have any
alternative liberal reason to say that
slavery is wrong if there is one or
exploitation is wrong or colonialism is
wrong or that freeing the slave was a
good thing I would like to hear it like
the the main the two main points he made
or like just summarize the points that
I've noted down he talked about racism
in Islam versus liberalism we talked
about slavery in Islam versus liberalism
and you said that okay but I also
mentioned al-ghazali at the very end no
I talked about something which you
missed out which is very important which
was actually the crux of my argument I
said that you you you are saying you
were using the words good and bad
yes yeah this is a good law opposes a
good lord is a bad law however I'm
saying good and bad is that which is
conceivable and acceptable and
legitimate within liberalism game you
have to address this point how can you
say that you as a liberal you believe
that apostasy killing the apostate is
wrong when actually philosophical itical
social and economic liberalism does not
object to it from a principle
perspective I'm not I John Locke just
because he said it was wrong I'm using
him as a as a supplementary evidence my
question is from a structurally
philosophical perspective how can you
prove that killing the apostate in a
state which claims to be say for example
Christian or Jewish is wrong on
liberalism okay okay great so the thing
is your conception of liberalism is
anachronistic because you're only
looking at
kind of you know 200 year old liberal
thinkers and yen you've constructed this
idea of liberalism that hasn't advanced
whatsoever okay and so yes it's true
that back in those times there were
people who at the same time were like
espousing ideas of like over the the the
sanctity of the individual and like
being individualist then also work being
contradictory in terms of slavery and
racism and so on and so forth okay but
you know we're not the Holden's for
those people and so the yeah and so and
so your your your concept of like you're
a liberal so why don't you think like
these people taking the structures of
social contract that you've taken this
not my okay that's the Wilding you talk
about liberals today but what is
liberalism
it depends okay it's liberalism social
contract can you have liberalism without
social contract so no I don't know if
you take away a social contract from
liberalism you have anarchy
okay it becomes a different ideology I
am saying the existence of social
contract allows for the universality of
law to trump the triumph over and above
the the individual's right to let's say
for instance freedom of expression of it
you can take this liberal as my argument
but you can take this individual idea of
liberalism of the you know the sacred
individual and additions infringe on
other people's freedom and then
extrapolate from that towards a caveman
artist or anarchist society well that's
all evolution then we've left liberalism
you've left what would what usually you
have to reject all you have to reject
your idea literally no but the thing so
you know I'd any of you because like yes
because well if you're if you're if
you're if you're trying to do is debunk
200 year old people I'm great
anyone today you want the punking desire
oh you have people who like value you
know you don't understand the argument
I'm not doing that I'm saying that all
liberal contractarian
by definition thinkers they have to
believe in a social contract nobody
I'm saying that principle hardly exists
today though though they all any liberal
that lives now whether they're
constitutional wherever they put them
social liberal Spore could you eat them
no no no no I'm saying that any liberal
from from this idea the individual
knowing being you know having rights
which would be considered like you know
in some respects a liberal idea they
they have like from that kind of gain
these ideas of a kind of fairness and
you know what's the word them not
entropy and poopy you know the world
empathy yeah they've they've gained
empathy like treating people the way
that you would like to be treated and so
on and so forth
you know and and what you're saying
doesn't applies them whatsoever I'm
saying understand the argument can you
have a political liberalism you managed
to knock down like have no you don't in
the 1800's you had like contra de 1800
and still managed to like forget about
those people I'm asking a simple
question I have one question is it
possible to have a political liberalism
without a social contract well I don't
know okay okay now second too much if if
you have a contract area if you have a
non-contract area understanding of
liberalism what you want to promote to
us then you can do that but what I'm
saying is that my argument is it's not
actually possible to have a to have a
non-contract aryan version of political
liberalism and maintain a full liberal
character you cannot be a liberal
without believing in a social contract
use your step into an anarchy that's my
idea which means you have no government
you might as well kill it everyone kill
it is the law of the jungle then so I'm
saying without social contract there is
no government there is no authority
there is no sovereign there is no
universal ality of law therefore what is
what is pertinent to a liberal discourse
is a social contract a political
liberalism my if you're saying that if
you don't know but I'm saying to you
this my argument that it's not possible
to have a political liberalism without a
social if that is the case then then the
laws that are there are sanctioned by
the political authority of the sovereign
the laws are sanctioned by that
authority and become univer Universal
eyes by law they are legit
there are the good thing there are what
is seen as good by liberalism